what images do we see from the rest of
the world we see natural disasters war
terror with the refugees and with a
horrible diseases right we see beautiful
beaches cute animals beautiful nature
cultural rights and stuff and then we're
supposed to make the connection in our
head and create a worldview out of this
and how is that possible I mean the
world seems so strange and I don't think
it is I don't think the world is that
strange actually I got an idea so
imagine the world as a street where the
poorest live on one end and the richest
on the other and everyone in the world
lives on this street you live there I
live there and the neighbors we have are
the ones with the same income people
that live on the same in the same block
as me they are from other countries
other cultures other other religions the
street might look something like this
and I was curious in Sweden where I live
I been eating quite a lot of students
and I wanted to know where would they
think they belong on a street like this
so we changed this houses into people so
this is this is the 7 billion people
that lives in the world and just by
living in Sweden most likely you belong
there to the richest group right but the
students when you ask them they think
they are in the middle and how can you
understand the world when you see all
these scary images from the world and
you think you live in the middle while
you're actually a top not very easy so I
sent out photographers to 264 homes in
50 countries so far still counting and
in each home the photographers take the
same set of photos they take this bed
the stove the toys and about 135 other
things so we have a forty thousand
images or something at the moment and it
looks something like this
so here we see it says on the top
families in the world by income and we
have the street represented just beneath
it you can see and then we see some of
the families we have visited and we have
the poorest to the left the richer to
the right and everybody else in between
as the concept says we can go down and
see the different families we have been
to so far here for instance we have
family in Zimbabwe one in India one in
Russia and one in Mexico for instance so
we can go around and look at the
families in this way but of course we
can choose if we wouldn't see some
certain countries and compare them or
regions or if we want to see other
things so let's go to the front doors
and see what they look like go here and
this is the world by front doors ordered
by income and we can see the big
difference from India Philippines China
Ukraine in these examples for instance
what if we go into the home we can look
at beds this is what beds can look like
doesn't look like the glossy magazines
doesn't look like the scary images in
media so remember that the students in
Sweden they thought they were in the
middle of the world income so let's go
there it's zoom in here by filtering the
street to the middle like this and then
I asked the students so is this what
your bedroom looks like and they would
actually not feel very at home so we go
down see do they feel more at home here
and they would say no this is not what a
Swedish typical bedroom looks like we go
up here and suddenly they feel sort of
at home and we can see here in this
image with the bedrooms in China
Netherlands South Korea France and
United States for instance so we can
click here if you wouldn't know more
about the family the home in which this
bed stands we can just click it and go
to the family and we can see all the
images from that family so we can go
this way too and of course this is free
for anyone to use so just go here and
please add more images of course my
personal favorite that everyone always
tries to make me not show I'm going to
show you
that's toilets because you're not really
allowed to look at people's toilets but
now we can just do it right so here we
have a lot of toilets look pretty much
as we're used to right and they are in
China Netherlands United States Nepal
and so far as Ukraine France and then a
pretty similar right but remember we are
in the top so what about checking all
the toilets now it looks a bit different
don't it so this way we can visually
browse through categories of imagery
using photos as data but not everything
works as a photo sometimes it's easier
to understand what people do so we also
do video snippets of everyday activities
such as washing hands doing laundry
brushing teeth and so on and I'm going
to show you a short snippets of tooth
brushing and we're going to start at the
top so we see people brushing their
teeth pretty interesting to see the same
type of plastic toothbrush is being used
in all these places in the same way
right some are more serious than others
but still that use rushes there and then
coming down to this poorer end then we
will see people start using fix and they
also might use their finger to brush
their teeth
so this particular woman in Malawi when
she brushes her teeth she scrapes a
Mudder from her wall and she mixes it
with water and then she's brushing so
therefore in the daughter street
material we have tagged this image not
only as her wall which it is but also as
her toothpaste because that is also what
she uses it for it so we can say in the
poorer end of the street you will use a
stick or your finger you come to the
middle you will start using a toothbrush
and then you come up to the top and you
will start using one each pretty nice
not sharing toothbrush with your grandma
and you can also look at some countries
here we have the income distribution
within us most people in the middle we
have a family we visited in the rich
Suren the Howards we can see their home
here and we also visited a family in the
poorer ends down here and then what we
can do now is that we can do instant
comparisons or things in their homes
so let's look in their cutlery drawer so
observe the Hadleys they have all their
category in a green plastic box and they
have a few different types and some of
them are plastic while the Howards they
have this wooden drawer with small
wooden compartments in it and a section
for each type of cutlery we can add more
families and we can see kitchen sinks or
maybe living rooms of course we can do
the same in other countries so we go to
China with pick three families we look
at their houses we can look at their
sofas we can look at their stoves and
when you see these those I think it's
obvious that it's just you've been thing
that we usually when we think about
other countries we think they have a
certain way of doing things but look at
these stoves very different right
because it depends on what income level
you have how you're going to cook your
food but a cool thing is when we start
comparing across countries so here we
have China and US and see the big
overlap between these two so we picked
the two homes we have already seen in
these countries the rules and the
howards standing in their bedroom pretty
hard to tell which one is China and
which one is us right both have brown
leather sofas and they have similar play
structures most likely both are made in
China so I mean that's a very strange
but that is similar we can of course go
down to the other end of the street
adding Nigeria so let's compare it to
homes in China and Nigeria
looking at the family photos they do not
look like they have a lot in common do
they but start seeing their ceiling they
have a plastic shield and grass they
have same kind of sofa they have stores
their grain in similar ways they're
going to have fish for dinner and
they're boiling their water in identical
ways
so if we would visit any of these homes
there's a huge risk that we would say
that we know anything about that
specific way you do things in China or
Nigeria while looking at this it's quite
obvious this is how you do things on
this income level that is what you can
see when you go through the imagery in
dollar Street so going back to the
figures the seven billion people of the
world now we're gonna do a quick recap
we're going to look at comparisons of
things in the poorest group beds roofs
cooking and observe in all these
comparisons their homes are show some so
they are in completely different places
of the world but what we see is pretty
identical so the poorest billion cooking
would look somewhat the same in these
two places you might not have shoes
eating if you don't have a spoon storing
salt would be similar whether you're in
Asia or in Africa and going to the
toilet would be pretty much the same
experience whether you're in Nigeria or
Nepal in the middle we have a huge group
of five billion but here we can see you
will have electric light most likely you
will no longer sleep on the floor you
will store your salt in a container you
will have more than one spoon you will
have more than one pen the ceiling is no
longer leaking that much you will have
shoes you might have a phone toys and
produce waste coming to our group up
here similar shoes Jordan us we have
sofas fruits hair brushes bookshelves
toilet paper in Tanzania Palestine hard
to distinguish if we would sit in US
Palestine or Tanzania from this one
Vietnam Kenya wardrobes lamps black dogs
floors so laundry cloaks computers
phones and so on right so we have a lot
of similarities all over the world and
the images we see in media they show us
that the world is a very very strange
place but when we look at the dollars
through the images they do not look like
that so using dollar Street
we can use photos as data and country
stereotypes they simply fall apart so
the person staring back at us from the
other side of the world actually looks
quite a lot like you and that implies
both a call to action and a reason for
hope
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]